stéphane dion le disais il est minuit
moins une et bien l'une des conséquences
désastreuses du réchauffement de la
planète c'est la montée des eaux
une tendance qui est dû en grande partie
à la fonte des glaciers mais aussi à la
dégradation des calotte du groenland et
de l'antarctique
depuis 1993 le niveau des eaux monde de
3,2 mm par année c'est deux fois plus
rapide qu'au début du 20e siècle
selon une récente étude américaine de
l'institut climate sancho même en
limitant le réchauffement à 2 degrés
celsius
le visage de certaines grandes villes
seraient complètement transformé
regardez c'est le cas de londres comme
ici près du parlement britannique ou
encore de mumbai près de la porte de
l'inde que l'on voit passablement
submergés et aussi new york dans le
quartier des affaires
mais imaginons un instant un scénario
catastrophe si le réchauffement était à
4 degrés celsius
voici à quoi pourrait ressembler les
rues de new york
donc cette montée des eaux elle a déjà
des conséquences concrètes christian
latreille et marcel khalifa se sont
rendus dans l'île de miami beach
c'est en floride une des destinations
touristiques les plus populaires du
monde mais aussi une des plus
vulnérables au changement climatique
miami beach en floride il de plaisir de
soleil et de plage
une ville où règne une insouciance qui
cache une course contre la montre
miami beach est menacée par le
réchauffement climatique
ici dans ce quartier cossu l'eau de la
mer monte depuis trois ans à des niveaux
jamais vus du leem
ça commence regarder l'eau monte l'eau
bouche par là
bientôt ça va venir ici à marée haute
en 90 minutes les rues du secteur sont
complètement inondée
toi c'est profond là c'est plus c'est
plus que 30 cm d'ici là le propriétaire
de cette maison de 10 millions de
dollars n'en revient pas ce n'est pas
drôle
le mois dernier le niveau est monté si
haut que lou est passé par dessus le
muret du côté du canal c'est la première
fois que je voyais ça ailleurs dans la
ville les canaux déborde des murets et
des sacs de sable sont utilisés pour
retenir l'eau temporairement mais les
bords de routes deviennent tout de même
des étangs où certains oiseaux en
profite pour pêcher nous avons un
problème un vrai problème
dang et nice est un ancien capitaine de
bateau devenu écologiste
il paye 20 mille dollars par année pour
assurer sa maison contre les effets du
réchauffement climatique
trois fois plus qu'il ya dix ans assurer
ma maison de miami beach me coûte plus
cher que mes paiements hypothécaires
c'est fou ce natif de miami crois qu'il
faut agir et vite
le consensus scientifique est indéniable
la mer va reprendre les côtes de la
floride
le niveau de l'océan va continuer à
augmenter
jusqu'à 60 cm en 2060 et d'environ un
mètre et demi au tournant du siècle en
2005 miami beach sera alors complètement
inondé la ville doit trouver des
solutions à plus long terme ils élèvent
les rues de 60 cm vous voyez la rue
serait ce niveau là peut-être plus haut
que 60 cm sa vamp est celle où d'inonder
la rue ici on a carrément surélever les
rues pour construire un système de
drainage souterrain ce secteur
commercial était constamment innover ses
propriétaires de cafés a même vu des
gens pagayer devant son commerce
les gens passaient un kayak
c'était fou une soixantaine de pompes
seront installés aux quatre coins de la
ville pour retourner l'eau à la mer 400
millions de dollars seront dépensés en
cinq ans pour tenter de garder miami
beach au sec
ce promoteur immobilier préside le
comité du maire sur la montée des océans
on n'a jamais pensé que l'océan montrait
il admet que tout le monde a été pris de
court temps vous serez lever les rues de
60 cm vous gagnez beaucoup d'années
et du temps miami en aura besoin pour
sauver son magnifique patrimoine
architectural art déco ainsi que son
écosystème exceptionnel
elle lui brille senio et géologue
il prépare un rapport sur les impacts
écologiques
il craint que la montée des océans ne
contaminent la vie aquatique
l'écosystème pourrait complètement
changer ça nous irait aux plantes dans
la baie et donc aux poissons aussi et
les touristes ne viendrait plus pêcher
ici aux réformes dit évoquant biel pour
pêche les écologistes et les
scientifiques sont inquiets et pourtant
encore bien des gens en floride ne
sentent pas d'urgence à miami on est un
déni de tous pas uniquement de la montée
des eaux
on le vit dans un monde parallèle brian
parents vendent des condominiums ici
depuis cet échauffement climatique ou
pas les condos de 5 10 et 25 millions de
dollars se vendent encore très bien
si vous parlez à bon nombre d'américains
qui habite à miami ce n'est pas qu'il
n'y croit pas mais c'est qu'ils n'ont
pas peur ils n'en sont pas effrayés
malgré l'éternel optimisme de certains
américains
d'autres se résigne déjà à quitter miami
beach on tente de gagner du temps pour
mieux s'organiser car les gens devront
déménager mon grand père et mon père
vide et ici j'ai passé ma vie j'ai 65
ans je ne peux pas partir mais je ne
suis pas idiot je ne suis pas dans le
déni quand lou sera aux juges n'auraient
pas choix nous n'aurons pas ce choix
leur paradis n'est peut être pas sur le
point de sombrer mais ses jours semblent
de plus en plus comptés